under a heavy police presence crowds
gathered on the tunisian capital's main
boulevard to protest against the
president
their anger's been growing since july
when kai said suspended parliament and
sacked the prime minister two months on
there's still no parliament no prime
minister and people here say no plan to
improve their lives
many of them were with the president
skyfield when he announced the 25th july
measures but they are now uh against him
because they they say that they they
were waiting for uh for uh effective
measures for the appointment of the new
prime minister now and they are shouting
slogan against him they shout shouted
slogan against tyranny and corruption
president saeed says his actions were
needed to address economic stagnation
and a poor response to the coronavirus
his critics are calling it a coup
and syed tightened his grip on power on
wednesday announcing hit rule by decree
and ignore parts of the constitution
but that constitution was a hard-fought
product of the 2011 revolution that
triggered the so-called arab spring
protesters say the president who's a
constitutional law professor is
endangering the progress that's been
made calling his actions a betrayal of
democracy
tunisia's largest political party in
akhtar is facing a crisis of its own
more than a hundred party officials
announced their resignation on saturday
accusing its leadership of failing to
counter syed's actions it's quite clear
that tunisians have just fed up with the
actual political elite or political
sphere the classic let's say political
parties
after 10 years of uh
following the revolution i think that
this this will gain maybe uh more and
more support this for this protest
depending on the economic situation in
the upcoming few weeks or months
local and international human rights
groups have condemned syed's actions
warning of a slide towards
authoritarianism
but they've also been demonstrations in
support of the president
kai syed has promised to uphold people's
rights
but there are still fears here of a
return to absolute one-man rule
alexi o'brien al-jazeera
all right we're going to speak to ahmed
galul on the phone now he's a member of
the executive committee of the henata
party and is at the protest in tunis
first of all sir can you just give me
your impression of what's happening on
the streets what's the mood
hi there and thank you for
treating what's happening to me
well uh mr kaiser has spoken about
legitimacy and today we can say
when we don't have
democracy democratic system
people will have to get their views
on the street
and what is happening today is that we
are and the people of tunisia are
defending their freedom there are tens
of thousands of people in the avenue
however
most of the roads meetings and waterways
leading to tunis are being blocked
people coming for tens of hours of drive
they are being deprived from reaching
the kind of
perception and the roads are being
really being narrowed so people cannot
come to protest against the crew however
the number which is there which is here
today
is quite
big that nobody can speak about it has
tens of people getting on the street to
demonstrate against the creditor
what are your demands of the president
our demands are basic
we need to go back to the prosecution we
need to go back to the floor we need to
go back to separation between powers
to the independence of the institution
of the state
we are a democracy
and nobody has the right to
break this system raise the democratic
system if one wants
to give the people the right to express
themselves there is no way other than
democratic means and tools
and what do you think will happen if
your demands are not met
well right now something has happened in
the country and people are starting
taking the street as a mean of
expressing their their views this means
that the public said and this means that
mr kaisaid is in a total isolation from
the tunisian people i cannot see any way
but one way that is going back to
constitution going back to democratic
institutions otherwise
we are going into a very dumpy uh i mean
road
in which we feel that our country will
not be able to secure food
to the people of the country to the
people of tunisia and i don't think that
mr kaisaid will be able to to deliver or
to govern in the way he wants to so he
will have to if there are tens of
thousands today tomorrow there will be
hundreds of thousands
america we appreciate your time and
speaking to us thanks very much indeed
that's the situation there in tunis
let's uh speak to
uh
to jamal shall now who's expert on this
really you've reported from tunisia many
many times including uh during the arab
spring um so jamal what's your sense of
what's happening here and how
representative is what we're seeing of
the national sentiment
i mean it's representative in the sense
that it shows there is widespread
opposition to the uh president uh and to
his decisions um obviously in
democracies the best form to judge
representation is through elections um
will point to the fact that he won
presidential elections but
those participating in the streets will
point to the fact that there was a
parliament which kai said decided to
suspend and that parliament came about
through elections and the vast majority
of the members of parliament are opposed
to uh the decisions that he made and
herein is the issue is
if kaisaid wants to turn to the streets
for legitimacy whilst he may have had
the upper hand on july 25th when he made
the announcements it's becoming
increasingly clear that he no longer has
that or is at least at risk of losing
the street um so therefore the the
choice is actually to go to the ballot
boxes what we're hearing from whether it
be another even other political parties
and even the trade unions um and members
of uh political parties who were
initially in support of him
for you to do that you need to respect
the constitution that's the constitution
that dictates what's happening and here
is the danger because what's triggered a
lot of people here is that whilst they
may have initially supported saeed's
decisions because he addressed them in
an
anti-corruption way emergency measures
that were needed to deal with the crises
both in terms of economy and in terms of
covid
people are questioning well if that's
the case why are you taking all power
and putting it and concentrating it into
yourself and why then have your
supporters gone out and burned the
constitution why then has he dismissed
the constitution of something that isn't
sacrosanct and doesn't need to be uh
respected to that uh degree right then
no the next question is if he doesn't
accede to demands of these protesters
what happens then we're already hearing
that how
access to the streets is being blocked
to a degree so where there's still time
for him is that the people here have
come out so far opposed to him opposed
to his announcement there isn't a clear
alternative in the sense that you have a
president a figure there in terms of the
opposition they're divided amongst many
different things all that unites that
all that unites the mother is their
opposition to these demands who is then
who is he going to negotiate tunisia has
set a model for other arab spring
countries in the pluralism that it
embraced through uh governing through
the troika which included different
political factions the
trade unions and so forth he's done away
with that in terms of his single-minded
approach
if he's able to convince people to come
to a negotiating negotiating table and
discuss that could be a solution but
i think when we're looking at this it's
still a bit early to talk about real
pressure being hyped up on him he's he
will be very much aware of this but when
i was listening into one of his speeches
just 48 hours ago where he said that you
know he was continuing uh with his
decisions and the path that he had
chosen and abated he doesn't really care
what's going to happen and he's going to
continue fervently that was not the
rhetoric of somebody who felt under
pressure either he's in denial and that
could be the case by the way because
nick
looking at tunisian state tv which
obviously he's running it's not even
showing these protests so he could be
very much hoping that he can ignore this
and it goes on but there's a lot of uh
people both internally in tunisia and
externally who are watching this you're
talking about european uh countries they
were the ambassadors of which went and
met him and put pressure on him you're
talking about now sound coming from
washington and pressure on the secretary
of state there to intervene so
if these protests continue for another
day or two or three there could be a
high pop in pressure on the president to
actually change his course right and
then we look also what the security
forces are doing what what's happening
they're going to be keep because
he used them uh in his announcement for
what his opponents call constitutional
coup what he calls uh extraordinary
measures where he made that announcement
with the generals of the uh military and
the police sitting around the table with
him uh but then again the tunisian army
if you remember back in 2011 and they
were very loyal to uh benally who ruled
with an iron fist for for almost 25
years refused ultimately to fight for
him and to to fire against the
protesters will he try and use them now
there are elements of what's been
described as the deep states who have
now reared their head back in with
basayid how they operate already they've
taken some sort of a side in the sense
that they've blocked roads preventing
anti-president uh protesters from taking
place but will they further that maybe
they're just doing that to see really
how big these protests are going to be
their role will be very indicative uh
and and we'll have to see how they play
now uh as these go on certainly seems as
if we're heading for some kind of
tipping point one way or another joel
thanks for that thanks very much indeed